J'ai appris que les dieux de l'Olympe sont
réels et parfois ils ont des enfants
avec des humains appelés métis.
jusqu'à présent,
qu'est-ce que c'est que d'aller à l'intérieur de la pitié de la tomate
Cronos une force alors même trois de ses fils
Zeus Hadès et Poséidon l'ont détruit,
il est destiné à se relever pour se
venger de l'Olympe et du monde, la
seule chose qui a le pouvoir de sauver
notre maison est  la toison d'or c'est dans une
mer de monstres mais les humains appelés
le triangle des Bermudes nos quêtes
n'appellent que notre meilleur héros le meilleur nous la
fille du dieu de la guerre
Barry ne t'inquiète pas de toujours venir en
second Jackson tu sais tout ce qu'ils
disent  à propos de toi c'est faux Clarisse nous
avons en fait toujours le sens de l'
humour c'est une mauvaise idée tu ne sais même pas
ce que j'allais dire tu vas dire
que tu cours après la toison en
fait il allait dire que nous étions son
char  de  la damnation ressemble à un
taxi de New York même différence
qui était géniale
nous allons ressusciter Kronos et les
Olympiens connaîtront la mort nous avons vraiment besoin de
votre aide et nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
temps vous dévissez le capuchon cela vous
libérez les vents du  quatre coins
du monde pas ici
nous trouverons une toison
dis moi ce ne sont pas des requins ce ne sont pas des
requins